I do freestyle rap that is improvised
rap made up in the moment based on your
suggestions it requires your input
requires everyone here to start thinking
of words topics and phrases you like a
rap about but there's some rules because
hip-hop but British hip-hop so
regulations number one you cannot
suggest food or animals that's the most
common thing our brains think of okay
don't don't come up with boring [ __ ]
number two don't mention anything I've
said like about babies or whatever
because that feels like I've tried to
hypnotize you for it and that's cheating
don't say anything British people don't
say anything weird in British you
[ __ ] love making it all about our
country you'll be there like
and like America doesn't give a [ __ ]
about our country so shut up
um and be exciting and be creative with
your suggestions don't just make them
simple and boring best suggestion ever
was a German man who said a day into
life of an Aztec high priest
make your rap about that English boy
I'll ask is that you you come with some
good ones so we'll take five suggestions
we'll divide the room up then we'll get
a beat dropping and we'll have some fun
if you are sat in this segment over here
what would you like to hear a rap about
dick
dick
I've heard all of those rules all of
those
just to make it as challenging as
possible and you were like I know what
I'm gonna say I don't give a [ __ ] what
he wants
t-i-c-k [ __ ] yeah well um
describe the dick in question
spot oh spotted oh very funny because
it's also a British joke as well
but okay so uh but we're gonna take it
as a penis because that's how it was
intended so a penis replete with spots
lovely
um you weren't even in that section you
were in this section
this section please be more erudite than
a dick with spots on that's suggestion
number one though what suggestion number
two gonna be
braces braces you mean um you mean
retain like orthodontic appliances or
braces and dick with spots on middle of
the room let's move away from this
whatever the [ __ ] going on over here
middle of the room what you guys want to
wrap up
first time in New York City um is that
you today
but it's them oh what's what's the most
shocking thing that what's the thing
that made you go oh wow we're in the
city now what's what what today that
made you think that
at the what sorry
is it also your first time having
alcohol what is occurring here wow okay
okay your first time in New York City a
dick with spots on braces this side of
the room there's two more stretches left
you've got a lot of [ __ ] intellectual
heavy lifting go needing to happen
because this is some dreary dire [ __ ]
really dull you guys
a New York right who wants be a country
mouse thank you for expanding this
beyond the Realms of the mundane and
then final section yeah
I said there were two Taylor Swift and a
safari in Africa
wanna will combine them why why can we
not do it yeah why can't she do that
Taylor Swift on Safari
um great a rat who wants to be a country
mouse people's first time in New York
City a dick with spots on and braces
this then lovely people it's gonna be a
freestyle that's a rat made up on the
spot based entirely on those suggestions
not written not prepared not rehearsed
um and don't worry it won't be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
Badger expecting it to be uh it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun and we'll
start with you
let me give you advice speed up when
you're walking here people shout at your
eyes on stalk it's clear you're seeing
the skyscrapers eyes are gogged your
slack you're saying this will do the job
the big city the Big Apple see a British
guy on stage try and start a rap battle
first time in Manhattan this guy rapping
you be going back in the evening lying
flatten your expensive hotel or Airbnb
like a fun day in the NYC where are you
from don't confront me maybe Ohio out in
the country somewhere you look around
and in your house got a tiny little road
and a very small Mouse like good now
Moon they're in the bedroom how back in
the day did he assume he would grow used
to be an ny sewera he says now this job
I'm not pursuing that I'm not doing this
move from the subway I need to run away
have a more fun way to live going out to
the fields get a bit of corn bit of hay
that I steal see a cow I'll see a sheep
and a goat that's incredible yeah and I
wouldn't even vote for Democrats because
usually in rural areas they're like
Republicans why because they think that
it's scary there yes they really can't
resist listen to country music by Taylor
Swift but she mixed it up she's from
there trying to change it get a new
genre we say yo Taylor do you feel me
she says my new albumin is in Swahili
why would you do that I must ask this
she says I've learned that African
language okay cool maybe have a dance
party where did you learn it out on
Safari dummy to Avenger if you're from
Kenya in the Maasai Mara she was there
it was trending walking around having
fun like the rat naming other animals a
giraffe and when you see a giraffe let
me think so quick dick so big got the
spots on that dick because it's there on
the skin they're on the hide this is
incredible the man he provides your
shout dick yes I've seen this the
transition seamless to the penis and
this dick so long getting so swole
showing it off at the watering hole and
then the doctor of the Savannah he sees
says giraffe sadly you've got an STD or
an STI can't get ready you got the
antibiotic resistant chlamydia and the
syphilis that's where the spots come
from I'm really sorry about this gotta
move on giraffe goes home have such fun
he says I'll get a [ __ ] from my wife
because her gums are incredible but
sadly beneath she went to the
orthodontist to fix her teeth oh no now
it's not what he admires he worries that
his pubes get caught in the wire when
he's getting sucked off by some one with
the braces I know it's horrible really
to face this I really don't mean to
insult these braces were clear on a
giraffe who was an adult
foreign